look I'll tell you right now I like a
tall woman you know I like a little
portable woman too but a tall woman well
I guess it's it's some men are feel
afraid of it some men will marry tall
women because they also want to marry a
man they consider him gay but but
they're afraid to either be gay or they
are not gay and so they just get a tall
woman that's hey you know they say you
know maybe I would love to have a man
but I'm not doing it
someone's going to get a tall woman you
know and cut her hair short put her in
jerseys and stuff you'll see a lot of
times you'll have a dude out there that
seems kind of like you know like he
could you know be for men and he'll have
his wife there and have her in a damn
Dennis Rodman Jersey or what are you
asking about oh I like a tall I like a
tall bird you know I like that lady hell
yeah that long that long lady I like
that run and jump up into that bitch's
arms you know what I'm saying I like a
tall I like a nine feet tall get that
bit way up there I can't even see her